joel it's clear to everyone who knows
you that you have some kind of weird
body dysmorphia
you are you are constantly
constantly i've been over to your house
to visit your
you your wife and your lovely kids and
you are constantly pumping iron and
doing all these exercises
um not necessary if you're a comedian
but you look fantastic i will say that
you got out and you look like
lou ferrigno uh you know
well i say for rig knew because that's
his actual name
people don't know that it is not his
actual name it is his actual name it's
ferrigno
uh as an n-e-u no no it's in
it's it's pronounced e because there's
an umlaut at the end
that's not yeah that's very true there's
no um in italian he's an italian person
not italian common misconception
is very talented no listen let's get
back to the real point which is that you
feel the need to have this massive
body with lots of muscles i could do
that
in an hour if i wanted to but i choose
not to
i don't well no we can see that
my point is this go ahead settle down
sona
thank you sona i'm noticing whatever you
are
i'm noticing that in a lot of your
projects oh no
okay it's a lady i thought she was she's
right she's right there
see that woman right there i don't think
that no that's just a card
actually it has a cardboard cutout hi
sona um
cardboard she's the cutouts work harder
on the show
[Laughter]
she's great come on zingaroo anyway um
i'm over here joel uh the point is i'm
drinking too much of the whiskey by the
way
i can tell you're actually starting to
amuse me oh
that's my problem wait no
so we can do this we can do this look
you're
bursting out of your shirt i can see it
what are you talking about because of uh
i know i'm not why you just sucked back
in no i didn't i didn't suck back in
uh you're sucking in right now nope not
at all
this is not at all not sucking your
chest
has grown with some uh you're like i'm
lactating you're like a bird
lactating see there we go okay so uh you
are
a man who's obsessed with having this
v-shaped uh
incredible uh adonis-like torso and i
applaud you for that
now it it occurs to me when i notice in
your different projects
you're always shirtless your shirtless
and scenes where you're getting money
out of an atm
yeah what's going on uh is that your
request
or is that well that particular scene my
head had been stolen
okay and i needed money to go buy
another shirt and
but all the shirt stores were closed got
it and that was the rest of the movie
uh yeah i remember that
dude where's my shirt oh that was it's
great
uh so i like to i do like to exercise
but my rule is
six hours a day that's it that's it
no nothing else uh i'm just
going through i'm in a deep uh
midlife crisis holding on to cause i
feel like i'm never gonna die you know
what i mean
yeah well wait you no no no you you are
i'm i'm very impressed i think we're all
impressed you walked into the largo
theater today and
it was it's nuts you know you've got
muscles where i didn't know muscles
could exist
i didn't know you could have muscles you
have a ridge of muscles here on your
shoulder
and then there's another muscle that
sits on top of that
the dorsamus thermo and i didn't even
know that existed
yeah well that's just from doing dips uh
but
you do only biking right not true you
don't do a lot of weightlifting
there's no way you're emaciated you're
you're you're
you look like you've escaped and haven't
eaten for days which is
yeah it's fine the look i'm going for uh
i'm looking for
civil war soldier that escaped uh
from andersonville uh which was the
prison compound where no one was fed
that's the look i'm going for how did
you pull that very specific
fact where which state is andersonville
in anton georgia
anyway so wait um i tried to get my wife
to visit
the site of andersonville shortly after
we were married because we were driving
through georgia
wait this is real oh this is true and i
told liza if we drive three hours that
way
we can go see a field where everybody
died of dysentery
and she said i regret marrying you
that's a
true story that's a true story unlike
your wild fabrications about you being a
money-grubbing creep but anyway um did
you go
she didn't let me go no i that's there's
nothing to see there
see this is why big empty field eliza
and i think
our wives are much better than us and uh
sarah because they
they talk sense into us and roll their
eyes
but let me get back to your because you
work out every day
no i work out a couple days a week i was
kidding uh
my rule is 45 minutes a day that's my
rule
and there's no way you only work out 45
i swear to you that's okay
my rule uh and if i because i listen to
a book
it's usually dianetics and uh
i listen to it endlessly and then i feel
great then i'm ready to go
seven thousand years incredible uh but
thank you for saying that
about i i look i'm about to i'm gonna be
50 this year so
i have to i have to really sandbag
because once that hits i mean look
what's happened to jeff
jeff ross our producer who he's going to
kill i should point out
bravely uh served his country in the
korean war
and uh that was after graduate school
right yeah yep
he's uh he's 94. now he's amazing he
looks incredible he's had a lot of work
done uh you really
jeff you really do look great andy
where's your green
uh does just uh discharge count
and you wonder why we're languishing in
an empty theater
you know you're wondering you know what
the rule in show business is gives the
people what they want
and my rule has always been no that
i want a sidekick who when you bring up
green says are you talking about my
discharge
that's what i've wanted that's what i
got and i've never been happier
and uh i'm in a with a cardboard
audience in an empty room
how awesome i'm here for you boss wait
how often have you been happy
sandy
discharge count ever been put together
by andy quite a bit okay i learned all
of the worst
grossest things when i started up the
late night show it was like joining the
marines because the first person i
hired practically was andy and then he
uh
has an encyclopedic knowledge of all the
most disgusting things in the world
which he proceeded to instruct and i was
my eyeballs fell out
and then i was i was initiated